mein persönlicher Lieblingstext aus
Mensch Erde wir könnten es so schön
haben ist ein Text über meinen Vater der
heißt der nachhaltige Turnschuh der Welt
der nachhaltige Mensch in meinem privaten
Umfeld ist mein eigener Vater er wurde im
Jahr 1935 geboren Ahrensburg auf der Insel
oesel in Estland kam nach Umsiedlung und
Flucht zunächst ins Allgäu dort wurde ein Lehrer
der Dorfschule auf ihn aufmerksam und empfahl ihn
für ein Stipendium für ein Internat so konnte
er später auch studieren und dabei meine Mutter
kennenlernen sie heirateten kamen vier Kinder
und deshalb tue ich mich auch schwer damit
wenn es heißt eines der wirksamsten Mittel zur
Reduktion des Ressourcenverbrauch sei weniger
Kinder in die Welt zu setzen das ist theoretisch
sicher richtig und ich habe höchsten Respekt vor
allen Dingen die das so für sich durchziehen
aber hätten meine Eltern sich daran gehalten
gab's mich nicht und ich bin Nummer drei lebe
sehr gern und ich liebe meine beiden Brüder und
auch meine Schwester die noch nach mir kamen der
ökologische Fußabdruck unseres Vaters und viele
aus seiner Generationen Macht über den Daumen
gepeilt mit über 85 immer noch nur ein Bruchteil
dessen aus was ich mit Mitte 50 schon verursacht
habe und auch weniger als das was durch Flugreisen
entferne Länder und den Verbrauch an Rohstoffen
auf die Kappe seiner 15-jährigen Enkel geht
mein Vater ging noch als Schüler barfuß zur
Schule damit die guten Schuhe länger hielten die
braucht man für den Sonntag die Hälfte wurden
mit Bleistift geführt damit man am Ende des
Schuljahres alles ausradieren und sie wieder
verwenden konnte dieser aus der Not geborenen
Sparsamkeit und Bedürfnislosigkeit blieb er ein
Leben lang träumen er besitzt bis heute immer nur
ein einziges Paar Turnschuhe Jahrzehnte lang ein
Paar blau-weiße adidas Rekord aus den 70er Jahren
vielleicht kann man das hier sehen so sie werden
sich daran erinnern sie kennen dieses Muster
nun muss man fairerweise sagen dass auch nie ein
großer Toner vor dem Herrn war aber es wäre ihm im
Leben nicht in den Sinn gekommen ein zweites Paar
zu kaufen solange die ersten noch funktionieren
ich kam auf diesen Vergleich als ich bei einer
Preisverleihung einem Vertreter der Firma adidas
zuhörte der lang und breit den ersten vollständig
Recycling gegen Performance Laufschuh lobte
sowie die Körper Social Responsibility bei der
Vermeidung von Plastikmüll ist bestimmt bereits
mehr als 11 Millionen Paar Schuhe aus Recycling
Plastikmüll zur Einordnung 2019 fertig der adidas
weltweit 450 Millionen Paar der nachhaltigste
Schuh ist immer der den man schon hat weil alles
an Aufwand material transport und Emissionen bis
auf die Entsorgung ja schon geleistet wurde so
wie bei meinem Vater spaßeshalber habe ich
mal bei Ebay geschaut und war erstaunt dass
die Blau-Weißen Schuhe aus seinem Schrank als
vintage heutzutage echte Sammlerstücke sind
mein Vater könnte die heute zu einem Vielfachen
des Einstandspreises verkaufen für 400 US-Dollar
aber auch das käme ihm nicht
in den Sinn herzlichen Dank
wie heißt du noch mal mit Vornamen Moritz
auf dem Moment habe ich mich schon gefreut
mit ihnen am Lagerfeuer zu sitzen das machen
Menschen seit Jahrtausenden Geschichten
zu teilen am Lagerfeuern ich habe versucht
Ihnen eine Geschichte zu erzählen von Diagnose
und Therapie als Arzt von den Krisen die uns
bedrohen und den Möglichkeiten die wir haben
gesunde und schöner zu leben alle zusammen
mein Wunsch ist dass jeder von ihnen
einen schönen Gedanken mitnimmt und vor
allen Dingen auch in die Tat umsetzt wenn gute
Geschichten sind dafür da sie weiter zu erzählen
manchmal wenn Menschen zusammenkommen in einem
Zelt um ein Medizinmann zu lauschen dann kommt
man auch auf die Geschichte von den zwei
Wölfen die in unserem Herzen wohnen der eine
will immer alles für sich der will Kampf Siegen
mit Macht und List und Tücke Wolf first und der
andere Wolf der möchte Spielen der möchte
Spaß haben er möchte eine gute Zeit haben
und manchmal gibt es auch im Publikum ein
ungeduldigen jungen Mann Moritz zum Beispiel
er will wissen Mensch medizinersachen endlich
welcher Wolf gewinnt das sage ich dir gerne
moritz ist gewinnt der Wolf den du füttert das
gilt nicht nur für dich das gilt für uns alle
und deswegen finde ich diese Wunderkerze an für
die nächste Generation die da kommen will denn
für mich ist das ganze Leben wie eine Wunderkerze
es brennt ab so oder so wundern müssen wir selber
das kann die Kerze nicht das können nur wir
werden geboren mit einem kleinen göttlichen
Funken werden wir ins Leben geworfen und
von Anfang an ist klar wir haben nur eine
begrenzte Zeit wenn das Leben endlich ist
wann fangen wir endlich an zu leben [Musik]
es gibt ein paar biologische Gesetze mit denen
wir geboren werden vermehrt dich und verzieh dich
und dazwischen gibt es ein paar spirituelle
Gesetze brennbar oder nicht brennbar
oder wer loslässt hat zwei Hände frei aber
dazwischen haben wir ziemlich viel Zeit das
Leben zu gestalten angeblich läuft er das ganze
Leben wenn wir sterben noch mal wie so ein Film an
unserem geistigen Auge vorbei und das ist für mich
ein sehr sehr starker Impulsen interessantes Leben
zu führen stellen sich vor sie sterben das Film
Leben kommt und sie langweilen sich das zweite Mal
das wäre doch schade
was kann man am besten mit seinen Fähigkeiten
mit seinem Inneren Pinguin tun man kann statt
sein Licht unter den Scheffel stellen dafür
sorgen dass es leuchtet das ist funkelt dass
man brennt für eine Sache und nicht ausbrennt und
dann kann ich mich darauf verlassen dass einer
dieser Funken irgendwo anders bei Ihnen oder
auch bei ihnen auf ein Feuer fällt und das ist
weitergeht wenn mein Feuer lischt darauf
hoffe ich da vertraue ich Ende [Applaus]